celebrations have been taking place in
Taliban health areas since an agreement
between the US and the Taliban was
signed in Doha nearly a week ago this is
a big achievement for all Afghans as the
local commander they lost and now we
have gained our freedom for civilians
caught in the middle a welcome relief
it's been very difficult there were a
lot of night raids the Taliban fighters
were escaping and it's civilians who
suffer we were the victims not the
Taliban the message here is that the
Taliban inflicted the historical defeat
on the US but there's another war going
on one between Afghans at least 80
attacks have been carried out since
Sunday killing dozens of people mainly
members of the Afghan security forces
the increase in hostilities was
triggered by Afghanistan's president
Ashraf Ghani refusing to release up to
5,000 Taliban prisoners as guaranteed by
the Doha agreement the Afghan government
did not take part in that agreement and
says this is a matter that should be
negotiated during the upcoming intra
Afghan talks the Taliban insists they
must be freed before the negotiations
start they need the data needs to be
freed sooner rather than later the
agreement has been criticized within the
Taliban's ranks and there are reports of
fighters defecting to other groups like
ISIL in the Doha Conference totally
derail the sale you know they have one
team but in inside there are differences
there are Taliban in Afghanistan there
are Taliban leadership in Pakistan they
don't agree they go by clans and tribal
systems and also politically there are
Taliban who are trained and educated in
one area there are predominant groups
who are educated in another area even
that has a difference the group feels is
now in a position of strength mullah
Geraldine Chan wari says it has also
evolved since the day he was Attorney
General of the Taliban government in the
1990s Taliban for cover
the Taliban is definitely the winner but
before we ruled alone that has changed
the Taliban wants to have a government
that will include all ethnicities but
there are red lines one is the
withdrawal of all foreign troops and
their advisers the implementation of
Islamic law is also a red line because
we paid a heavy price but whether the
country is called Islamic Emirate or not
is open to negotiation the government
wants a Taliban to disarm after agreeing
on a ceasefire but attacks are likely to
continue just as they did during
negotiations with the u.s. leaving
Afghans paying the price once again head
up the Hamad Al Jazeera Cabo